come on lady let us in all right that's
us on the poster
see
now my vision may not be what it used to
be but that there's a poster of some kid
and this here is a poster
of some old y'all fans are gonna freak
out because zombie 101 is back
how exciting is this okay y'all gotta
spill the beans jamie you can go first
what is it like for you to jump back
into this character all these years
later
when i first walked on set it was
overwhelming seeing everyone all at once
um but in a good way and this is
was a very quick reunion kind of really
just for us to get to see each other
again
and see if we still have that chemistry
it was still there and it was
so i think for me it was just kind of
one of those things that assured me that
you know the fans have been wanting it
and then figuring out is it doable
and um this is really fun we did it
where it all began
where i literally got my start on all
that and nickelodeon
and i played two characters so it was
just really
a lot of fun it felt right to me and um
hopefully we get to do it again i know
fingers are so crossed right now but
i've seen the reunion but we want to
give fans we don't want to spoil
everything for them
but we want to give them a sneak peek
into what exactly the reunion skit
entails of course it was on all that so
jamie can you just set that up a little
bit more
well this little reunion is
the zoe 101 cast trying to get into all
that to watch
you know watch them film live and there
is something in their way
miss thelma stump the oldest bodyguard
in the business
who i also play but as always zoe comes
to the rescue
as she tends to do and we all get in
and we get to um you know go have some
fun together like we used to
did she just call us old yeah yeah i
will find a grandma
oh yeah you want to come here
john when you got the phone call and you
were like
the cast is getting back together so we
wanted one reunion
what was your reaction to that uh
something similar to the one that i just
sort of emoted just now
i mean i was super surprised then again
i had already had the privilege of
getting together
with some of the guys beforehand some of
the girls as well we had a little dinner
jamie wasn't able to make it at that
night but that's okay
she was working yeah exactly she was in
atlanta
you know making the big bucks but anyway
i was i was like what
are you kidding me this is crazy i i
can't believe i get to see everyone
again i can't believe i get to see jamie
again
it was it was awesome it felt like sort
of a dream
that had just come true so it was really
sweet i just loved it
it was fun yeah we all are gonna love it
and chris have you guys been able to
keep in touch
as much as you had hoped you would or
you thought you would
yes i i um without trying to i guess i
played kind of like
really the liaison between everyone
yeah i'm the glue i think i just i
always reach out to everyone kind of
checks on everyone to make sure
everyone's good
and it was really cool because uh now
we're all in like a group chat
so we have it's called like pca alumni
so we can all kind of like text each
other and be like yo
you know what's up you know hey i got
this coming you know on saturday if you
guys want to make it
so it's cool you know everyone's kind of
like in touch again
it's always awesome
it's my fault we're late did we miss
anything good
nah you didn't miss much it's nothing
important
no good cause cheers
[Applause]
when we last saw the show in so that was
in 2008 reunions i didn't feel like
we're as popular as they are right now
reunions
reboots you know like a 2.0 version of
stuff
so you probably thought you'd all left
it on the dance floor at prom right
and paul here you are going back you
know kind of
rekindling this nostalgia and memories
picking things back up with 101
so what are you are you you thinking
that fans are going to get super pumped
about it and hopefully
this will be something yeah i mean from
my end
i have like a not like the fans
constantly are reaching out just wanting
to see us all together i i feel like the
show is kind of like
the like nickelodeon's version of
friends if friends was like
at school and then like people have just
connected to these characters
so hardcore and like just like we are a
family i feel like
the fans like they grew up with us and
they want to see us where we are now and
they want to see they want to
a window into our lives again and they
we all have such fun interesting pers
unique personalities and they want to
see that
literally i can post a video wearing
this and it will get
millions of views just because the fans
are just so excited to see a sweatshirt
wait i need to do that again let me see
let me see
i got the key too i came prepared
mine so the fans they go crazy for
anything zoe related
i think they're more than ready and i i
just hope we can make them happy
so good aaron and kristen so all y'all
got some swag from set
to commemorate your time with the with
the show
yeah we got a nice little orangutal
parka
yeah yeah we got like some big jackets
i actually also dug out my pca
sweatshirt
i'm impressed i was able to find mine to
be completely honest it's been so great
too because like again when we went to
back to the side of all that they all uh
imported
our jackets with our names and then all
that and everything so it was such a
cool little gift to go home with and all
of us were just rocking it after
we shot for that day as well too a lot
of fun oh hey look at this letter jacket
i love it so many great memories but
y'all are like the age of the kids that
are shooting on that
all that now so it's just kind of like a
full circle moment
i gotta say jamie this must come at a
very special time for you because i
caught up with you at the beginning of
quarantine with maddie your precious
maddie
and you know now you're having the
opportunity to
introduce your girls to zoey it's really
strange to look at
my now 12 year old and be like oh my
gosh like i was on a show at this point
it's bizarre i'm like
i can't imagine but then i see all the
things that she does that are so amazing
i'm like i could have never have stepped
up in those ways so it just really is
cool to like
be able to um you know put myself where
where she is and what i was doing at
this time and of course
you know only thing she really cares
about is like tick-tock even though she
doesn't have an account she's not
allowed to yet but
you know i think that that's what's
really neat about it is able to i'm able
to
have a different perspective that i
think is important as we
hopefully go on this next journey is
seeing my children see me
when i was their age it's really bizarre
you think maddie will get to see you for
a full-fledged reboot of zoey 101
um that's the plan so you know maybe she
could play you know like
zoey when she was younger or something
but yeah the plan is a reboot
but it's just you know quarantine and
all of this stuff i think
um putting everyone's safety first is
what we're trying to do right now
and conversations that were started
before this
have you know kind of took a slow pace
as everything else in the world did
and reasonably so so i think that um you
know we're still having the
conversations and figuring out
how to tell the story in a way that is
going to do it justice because we want
it to be good we want to relate to the
fans that's why the show worked in the
first place
because we connected to our fans and
where they were in their life so i want
to make sure that we find the home
and the best story to tell to do the
same for the fans
[Music]
well this is going to give us a nice
little tease and taste of what's to come
you all remember this song
there might be something in the works
with that very soon so hopefully
um so hopefully you know quarantine is
brutal for everyone so i'm just trying
to kind of like
space out little goodies for everyone
yeah here's the zoe fans so
yeah yes and then hopefully a theme song
possibly
that will be a little bit of a newer
version
okay well you are the queen of like
keeping things under wraps because y'all
like i said
i just caught up with her a couple
months ago and she was tight-lipped
about this
reunion skit that y'all shot back in
november
jamie lynn unbelievable honestly i just
forget
i'm just like too many kids that's the
problem i'm
not secretive i just don't remember what
happened yesterday
how many kids and too many tick tock
videos guys
y'all are all over the place when it
comes to social media
doing a little tick tock fun i feel like
this could be
a good way to get fans excited and get
them in
on the reboot the reunion all that jazz
so what's maybe like a tick tock
challenge that you could throw out there
to fans to get them pumped
as they're watching this skit on all
that well honestly i think paul has the
most um
insight there because any insight i have
comes from my 12 year old so
i mean me and jamie lynn actually did a
dance challenge to the theme song so
there's that
we could uh you could go and join in on
our dance challenge
uh yeah at the quarantine i forgot yeah
yeah exactly
[Music]
or i mean i always thought that like
people could show their different friend
groups you know how like the theme song
it showcased
each one of us they could play the theme
song and showcase their friend groups
and like
characterize their who they would play
something like that would be fun
in my opinion we'll have to get creative
yeah you got to get creative i
personally want to get the whole cast on
tick-tock i'm like mr tick-tock and i
would love to do like the group dances
or the group challenges with them and
just like get people hyped seeing us
when we're allowed to safely feel like i
gotta start taking dance classes now
no no no apparently there's a whole
different dance whole new set of rules
with tick-tock oh yeah
it's not real dance it's like there's
tick-tock dancing it's
very confusing let me tell you something
i would love to see
you and brittany do like a social tick
tock
graham battle because girl you were
pregnant with the dance moves on the
tick tock
and brittany's always crushing it on the
insta game yeah
i mean i think honestly when it comes to
dancing i'm not going to compete with
her because uh
she's proven that she's pretty she's
she's she's got me beat there
so honestly i think that um you know i
think during quarantine everybody's just
trying to
we're all reminiscing a lot on just
literally going to the grocery store in
a normal fashion
so reminiscing on like some of our best
times in life whether it's
i did it again or whether it's you know
just doing something for fun to connect
with people whether it's dancing or
whether it's a tick tock it doesn't
really matter i think that
we should all just be um we should all
just be trying to connect to each other
so
honestly i don't i'm not going to battle
my sister in dance
i've already lost before i've even
started
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey